what's up guys this is international
master Eric Rosen and welcome to another
video in this video I'd like to respond
to a YouTube commenter whose name is
Oliver Kay boster she is a pretty boss
name and he was asking about what to do
in the Sicilian when they don't play an
early d4 but they play an early night of
3 in Bishop c4 so the line he gave me
was efore c5 Knight of 3 d6
and Bishop c4 and he told me he's a
dragon player and he encounters this I
guess on an occasional basis and he's
not quite sure what to do so I will say
that Bishop c4 is completely fine move
and you're not gonna be able to be
winning after this move but I would
recommend maybe playing something a
little bit different than what you're
used to in kind of a normal dragon now
normally if you are a dragon player you
can go ahead and play something like g6
Bishop e7 and io6 and castle and got a
completely playable position but what I
would recommend against Bishop c4 is e 6
and the idea is to exploit Bishop c4 as
much as possible and what you're doing
with e6 is you are undermining the
bishop so it's not as effective just
kind of staring at your solid pawn chain
and a long-term idea for black in this
opening is to eventually play this move
d5 so let's say white will continue
let's say like castles and now the moves
I'm playing here for white are just kind
of based on what I've seen
beginners play I have a lot of students
who might play against this as black and
I see a lot of white players just kind
of playing kind of standard normal
developing loose and what I want to show
is a potential trap that white could
walk into so let's play some some normal
moves for for both sides let's say d3 I
usually like to
the bishop on e7 I should note that if
you're gonna put your pawn on e6 usually
you shouldn't combine the movie six with
the move g6 because it's a usually a
little bit too weakening so this should
be seven very standard here Knight c3
Castle and let's say white walks into
the trap now one of the most natural
looking moves here for white is actually
a terrible terrible mistake that move is
Bishop to e3 and from this point on
black is uh is winning material and if
you haven't seen this before it can be
so much shocking and I would encourage
those who haven't seen this before to
pause your video and find the material
winning move for black so the move is
very simply pawn d5 and the point is
that black is going to end up forking
white so if white takes and black takes
d5 or d4 is coming and white has to lose
a minor piece no matter what so I fish
up to be three d5 let's say Bishop take
take black has won a piece for a pond
with a significant edge and it won't be
all the time that whites will fall into
this trap but it's always nice to have
kind of a a trap that your opponent
might fall into and it's always nice to
know an opening where there is a trap
because sometimes it's a bit more
motivational to play it let's say white
doesn't fall into the trap and let's say
white plays perhaps a more standard or
better remove like rook e1 blacks plan
is simply to continue development black
wants to play knight c6 and the
long-term plan for black in this
position is something you'll see a lot
especially and maybe more close to
sealing positions is black wants to
expand on the Queen side and the very
simple idea is to play six b5 and
sometimes that can be supported as well
with rook the eights and if we perhaps
play some moves for whites let's say
white doesn't play Bishop e3 which would
be bad again but plays some move like
this
to g5 then very simply a6 afy prevents
this let's say a for this will
occasionally happen
what black can do another fan is to play
Knight to d4 and this is a move which if
you play the Sicilian you should kind of
become accustom with it's a move to not
only try and gain more space but be a
bit more aggressive and and create some
some pressure in White's position and
you should not be scared of night take
t4 because after a pawn take d4 yes you
do have double pawns but after this move
92 you have a few different ways of
playing here maybe the the most obvious
way is to play e5 and just kind of
secure your pawns and really there's not
too many problems with this position for
black buy the more aggressive way of
playing and the move I really like here
is pawn d5 and what this does is it
kicks the bishop
if kwon-taek g5 you can actually take
with Knights and some trades might
happen but but then your pawn on d4 is
well reinforced and it's not a bad
position for black so I think I hope
some of this answered answered what to
do against Bishop c4 I think kind of
knowing your piece placement is one
thing that will be helpful in the
opening but then the other thing is kind
of understanding how your setup will
dictate your plans and in this case
especially with sealing positions these
plans of expanding on Queen side and
going for central play are important to
know and it's the type of position where
if you kind of know it ahead of time
then you can play it over the board and
I have to be trying to come up with
ideas over the board so I hope that
helped for people who might have kind of
similar questions feel free comment
below and I will see you guys in the
next video